lumières machin on bouge plus
[Musique]
105e bon je vous faire une nouvelle
interview pour vous spécial pour vous
celle là c'est l'interview psys ont
largement je suis là faire à pied à vélo
ou bien alors c'est très simple insu
vous citez tout un tas de maladies
pathologique psychologique et et de
perversion et vous avez bien si vous
êtes comme ça exhibitionniste de moins
en moins ah bon ouais ouais
fermez fermez les volets non je crois
que c'est le fait de faire de la scène
me permet d'accepter de l'être moins
d'être plus pudiques maintenant c'est
comme moi les gens viennent finalement
je vois des gens tellement bien dans les
missions que j'ai pas besoin d'en faire
c'est beau comme cette nourrice embête
pas mes chiens une ans a fait une sortie
attendue sera évident moi ça fait cinq
mois et demi je suis pas sorti et
chandon terminer un roman
voilà là il a un peu mal grizzlies
complètement mais moiselle michel et
très grise mine ce soir auprès de
répondre à pierre s'ils voulaient alors
masochiste vous savez quand vous fasse
mal
j'ai des mauvaises habitudes à ce niveau
là encore c'est à dire que mais c'est la
dernière fois
c'est à dire que je crois vraiment que
dans le le sadisme masochisme et a
beaucoup qui nous vient enfin comme tout
d'ailleurs qui nous vient de déchets
mâcon a appris et que si on a vu des
gens d'autres familles qui sont
malheureux on a tendance à se dire ah
bah ouais c'est vachement bien être
malheureux et la tendance à l'être voilà
donc je me soigne alors est ce que vous
êtes schizophrène dédoublement de
personnalité
non non non aucune saisie oui je crois
par il a un petit peu oui parfois oui
pierre mais pas par an mais ce motant
clip oui on est un peu parano c'est
normal comment on expose et vend des
forcément par un essai c'est vrai ce qui
est lui résiste difficilement du réseau
c'est quoi ça alors maintenant offerts
dont j'ai arrêté des demandes est à dire
d âge non hystérique vous êtes heu
pardon j'ai déjà rien tout neuf à douze
ans
voilà est-ce que vous avez de la
narcolepsie c'est quoi ça c'est quand on
s'endort n'importe quoi n'importe
comment j'arrive à m'endormir maman
dormait jamais maman dormait nous attend
mais mais c'est pas le contraindre à la
pathologie c'est mériterait bien dans
notre métier de pouvoir dormir un quart
d'heure et là leurs collègues si c'est
quand on sait pas quand on va s'endormir
oui c'est vu des chiens comme ça c'est
génial centre a trait aux blessés ils
sont très contents et ils jouent alors
plaint arriver raymond barre c'est ça
qui l'attend mais sérieusement vous
savez la mamba c'est ce qu'il a la colle
et psy écoutez je m'endors à toutes les
conférences y compris parfois aux
miennes la formule c'est quoi
j'existe peur d'eux des films pornos non
c'est bien il n'aime pas du tout les cas
de cette bande est ce que la porno
phobie c'est quand on a peur de l'acte
sexuel
c'est marrant ce cas voilà ça vous son
salaire de bus ont cessé il ya un truc
terrible j'avais trouvé la pente aux
phobies on touche au but gérard
déconnade nord c'est le pur de talent et
à sa vie c'était pas bête celle là
c'était pas mal le serveur alors
maintenant hop le port des pantalons
non
ça vienne portent tous bien sûr c'est
avant tout ce qui veut dire tout ça
honte aux phobies c'est d'avoir peur de
tout il ya des gens comme ça moi on
verdict vous n'êtes pas si folle que ça
je m'emmerde
on se rallumer la lumière les chiens on
va peut-être une petite interview
l'oms et ya un petit peu quand même
caractériel j'étais interne ou psy alors
attention là parce que pendant le jingle
vous avez l'habitude les garçons bouge
pas il faut pas bouger
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as un peu bougé j'ai regardé rouge
caméra il fallait retenir son souffle
tout tout tout tout ça mais non c'est
dur c'est cette émission est un peu dur
des retraites milite à la respiration
les invités me le disent souvent un
petit richard non m'avait dit que dans
cette école genre de blague
non666 avenue de l'opéra à l'an 2000 ce
rappel ne sera pas bon alors richard
bohringer vous êtes prêts oui alors
interview psy donc un est-ce que vous
avez des toc c'est à dire des tous des
troubles obsessionnels compulsifs tir
gens vous remontez fermer le gaz de
l'eure voulais faire mais oui oui oui
attention parce qu'on ne touche et la
femme policier déclaré fu piste et oui
ça sera plus la baisse de 26 à sera une
camisole anvers et à la fin on me semble
que vous êtes parano oui est ce que vous
êtes schizo oui est ce que vous êtes
salle d'eau non attendez on n'allait pas
sado vous aimez pas faire mal n'ont même
pas pensé le bout des seins n'ont même
pas passé
moi je suis là aussi pour faire plaisir
oui à temps et si ça fait plaisir de
passer le bout des seins si ça fait
plaisir je fais mais je suis passé à
dommages aux il ya des filles qui ça
fait plaisir c'est la crise
alors est ce que vous êtes exhibo non
vous vous baladez pas à poil devant la
plaine voisine qui non non non ya pas
deux voisines scato ah non alors jusqu'à
thonon travelo non tu dis rien [ __ ]
c'est la roue non je ne suis pas bon est
ce que vous êtes
hypo est-ce que tu as une fois go ça
pouvait faire partie de ce que vous êtes
fous rires est-ce que vous êtes
hydrophobe je ne sais pas mais j'ai
arrêté je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire
laure denis drôle au globe j'aime pas
j'aime pas l'eau à j'aime là aussi ça
vous aimez le maroc ait connu l'orangé
bleue
non ici par ici ouais j'aime je ne vais
jamais rien
les africains nikto fob je vous rassure
tout de suite ça il ne cherchait pas un
truc niki lauda ça veut dire quoi la
fois beatnik non non ça c'est porno fob
jet porno fob non ouais donc nikto
femmes non c'est des gens qui ont peur
de la nuit tout simplement vous n'êtes
pas une sofop non non non est ce que
vous êtes benno non baîllonné fob c'est
pas ça le oui alors c'est la peur de
bruno bellone aujourd'hui non je suis
qu'un agent de la piqûre
ah non non pas du tout pas du tout et
pour terminer à ce que vous êtes à nemo
fob bon c'est pas le mec qui aime pas
anémone un démo faute c'est le mec aime
pas le vent ah non moi j'aime j'adore le
vent en ce moment vous avez été servis à
prendre forme aussi que j'avais appris
avec une pente au fox et celui qui aime
les pantoufles voile avant celui qui a
peur de tout voilà un bien
yann faure la forme en province mais bon
là d'ailleurs on valoir cédé mardi à
progresser vacances en thaïlande après
ce temps les massages thaï non j'ai pas
pris mais vous marierai jamais j'ai des
copains qui ont essayé et ça pas voulu
me raconter bas à huy sont allés faire
des cobayes vous avez je mettais en
thaïlande dont jamal n'ont pas acheté
avant d'être avec elle toute façon je
vous laisse dans les mains de linda
alors là attention donc c'est
l'interview je sais la zone jugée trop
attention attention
richard si vous étiez une femme à qui
meurent y est vous ressembler à ma femme
benoît
et vos plantations
la non des fantasmes qu'elle serait
bouffant tu as écouté quitte à vous
décevoir ses basiques moi ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que chose toute simple
je fais les oui je fais ce qu'il fait
plaisir et donc si vous étiez cette
femme à la vôtre quelle serait sa serait
pas de pire cauchemar si vous deviez
vivre avec richard bohringer
ben c'est de vivre réglé c'est vrai que
là en l'occurrence
ça devrait partir tous les deux sur une
île déserte
pascal programme le programme de fait
une île déserte vraiment désert ouais
oui ça veut dire personne d'autre non ça
veut dire faire ça autrement on n'y va
pas non non ils apportent cio peut être
tous les deux au milieu des autres
mondes
vous avez dit un jour la générosité des
hommes s'arrête là où commence celle des
femmes fois nous expliquer parce que je
trouve plus généreuse que nous pas
l'alchimie tous les gonzesses dans la
poche sont deux heures heureuses ce
cadre il ya d'autres trucs moins
plaisante d'accord n'a pas de poche dans
son truc
georges wolinski arts a dit un jour ça
c'est pour notre dernière question les
hommes adorent les connes c'est pour ça
qu'ils ont tout fait pendant des siècles
pour qu'elle le reste
c'est très joli mais c'est un mot c'est
un goût très spirituelle mais non sur le
fond on peut profiter de liste merci
nana je crois que vous l'avez l'idée
c'était
déstabilisé quand c'est un peu un pari
sharks et vise à déstabiliser tard et
bien finie vous avez fait quoi là je
vais faire je vous tester en valeur les
is equal aux tests c'est l'interview psy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
midam c'est thierry ardisson est capable
d'expliquer on ne bouge pas pendant les
jingles non c'est guy bedos
bon alors allons-y c'est tout simplement
c'est une interview psy c'est pour
savoir quel est votre état psychique
après une semaine en baisse et lien pour
ça c'est un peu plus intimes comme ça
pour savoir quel est votre état
psychique après une semaine de promotion
sur la plage
est ce que vous êtes dépressives ou je
vous êtes névrosé non coût zéro défaut
tlc 0 des zombies parano ça m'arrive
dans quelles circonstances
plusieurs camps votre jules tourner avec
leonardo dicaprio est un peu mais je le
vis très mal
vous êtes schizo non cela qui nous a
tous histoire mais je vais est-ce que
vous êtes exhibo annonça se disent avec
nadia chèque et donc on est un peu exigu
quand on est actrice en même temps ça
fait frémir exhibo mais je pense pas que
ça je dis comme ça dit quoi choisir de
digoin dit exhibitionniste ribot
franchement exhibo d'y exister wendy
exhibe y exhibe lycée quand on est venu
est-ce que vous êtes alors ça c'est très
drôle
est ce que vous êtes porno fob c'est ce
que ses parents
je ne suis pas supporter le porno c'est
la première que je vois qu'ils
connaissent à des insultes des cônes ou
quoi tard mais attendez vous avez toute
trouvée là parce que c'est du grec
ancien vous allez voir c'est du grec
ancien à les voir je vous êtes sado inde
un nécessaire une petite perversion
parce que vous êtes sac à dos est ce que
vous êtes en virginie ledoyen aussi la
paire généralement coco comme c'est
minime hystéro nous gérons tôt à un peu
quand même dit la vérité là j'ai la
réponse une façon peut-être pas mentir
c'est quoi dire entre géronto gln les
gens un peu plus âgé qu'elle et virginie
à bien encadrer l aime bien avoir des
gens elle a bien être avec des hommes un
peu plus mûr c'est sexuel géronto c'est
à dire c'est l'attirance gérontophilie
c'est la france qu'on a pour des gens un
peu plus âgées les jeunes qui va là tu
te ridiculises xavi d'être étudiés c'est
la dernière fois qu'ils nous inviterons
à dîner les auditions sont identiques à
leurs 10 ans sont gentils fétichiste non
voyeuriste un peu quand même unique mois
d'été pour moi je mesure ce qu'est ce
que permet à ce palais des fonctions de
serre version électrique aura fabien
coupa les agoraphobes elle n'aime pas la
foule
ah je croyais elle avait peur des
araignées se moquer du il ya que vous
pouvez trouver ça est ce que vous êtes
keno fob à je sais moi ça en plus elle
ne sait quoi qu'elle fasse elle a peur
du mari de barbie
oui
ouais
[Applaudissements]
gp du grès concert k'do fob 11 ans et le
club c'est celle qui a peur de
l'obscurité
moi j'ai appelé ça nuit fob justement
est-ce que vous êtes nikto fob nungesser
nous c'est ma ce qu'on croit non sérieux
sérieux mixte à la nuit à la dignité
jean castaings la nuit voilà c'est son
nom est ce que vous êtes et lourau fob
alors si tu sais pas par contre ça c'est
la honte c'est d'être pas elles auront
pour leur argent
innovaphone est-ce que c'est maxime et
l'europhobe c'est comme si jean campeurs
des chats est ce que vous êtes sinophobe
maxime un maxime il n'est pas si le fab
dans la baie de somme ils sont pas si
nos familles cynophiles ils sont
cynophiles
on s'est compris le complicité entre 94
et ce avec quoi je me demande ce que tu
toi écrite en race toile crâne comme un
jeu serré c'est le plus dur
est ce que vous êtes aérodrome au fob 3
la géniale c'est une affaire tout le
monde croit que c'est la peur des
aérodromes
non non c'est la paire les aéroports
c'est la peur des avions dont elle avait
dit sophie est ce que vous êtes sidero
d'homophobe sociaux et non la fois
arrêter ce jeu par contre si bertrand
hoffer ces agences ont peur du train
thaïlande elle a fait 4 mois c'est
pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes coco fob
mais on adore la noix de coco
non pas du tout non tu possèdes pas coco
termine bien ce qui est formidable c'est
derrière sow et cafards expliqué on ne
bouge pas pendant le jingle ça c'est
formidable c'est des normes dites moi
intérieur si donc on va faire un petit
tour de votre psychisme d'accord est ce
que vous êtes parano ça m'arrive donc l
occasion mais j'ai droit à des jockeys
ou pas avec toi mais si vous savez si
vous prenez des jokers c'est anconina et
géra qui répondent à votre place non je
suis parano quand je suis pas très bien
dans ma peau et quand
préféré répondre vous finalement être
fumé trop de cigarettes
c'est dégueulasse arrêtez vous avez
arrêté à moitié fou est adorable
est ce que vous êtes schizo pas du tout
enfin ça peut non non ça va de ce côté
là ça va est ce que vous êtes maso non
enfin envers moi même ça peut m'arriver
aussi vous fait du mal je vais pas me
faire du mal à moi même way est ce que
vous aimez quand vous fasse du mal non
non non ne vous plaît pas ça est ce que
vous êtes sado vous aimez faire mal non
ce n'est pas sûr non non ça me plait pas
bien jusque là ça va
est ce que vous êtes sado maso ça rend
la prod uss
c'est bien connu
non mais je préfère qu'elles soient
douces en douceur donc j'ai pas du temps
pour la violence est ce que vous êtes
géronto je sais pas ce que c'est geron
tous ces défis qu'elle vient les vieux
vieux vieux je sais pas ce que c'est
exactement vieux non plus je comme moi
quoi
mais moi je ne trouve pas dieu par
exercer non mes vieux genre dieu à
partir de 60 70 non je suis pas géré en
toi là oui d'accord mais jusqu'à quel
âge vous êtes jusqu'à quel âge et
agiront temps à partir de quel âge j'ai
pas 50
ça va encore est ce que vous êtes porno
je pas vous aimez regarder des cas c'est
des machins dans ce sens là pas du tout
pas du tout non je suis pas du tout bord
noir j'aime pas ça alors je peux être
porno mais pas par vous regardez jamais
de films pornos paraîtra jamais non
franchement ça me vous ferriez retrouve
pas dans le dos c'est normal comme fille
a assez vous ne regardez jamais non plus
vous riche à moi je regarde pas parce
que le camion sert presque jamais qu'il
faut attendre un quart d'heure si on
s'en sert pas pendant huit jours c'est
mal foutu cette histoire c'est quand
même qu'il faut attendre un quart
d'heure
et non
et nous jamais pas faire participer moi
à oui oui que le voir à la télé suivront
c'est marrant mais moi je préfère
participer
ouais fait rétracte est ce que vous êtes
bedo celle inverse de géronto je dis ça
pour nos amis téléspectateurs qui n'ont
pas l'habitude de tous ses maux et doan
ont pedu non plus vous êtes au jeu vous
êtes travelo vous a déjà tenté la disant
vous êtes vachement sérieuses comme
fille
vous avez vu moi c'est le truc noir
mollahs que je suis la rdc les
déviations les plus communes des
français c'est vrai c'est le top 15 des
déviations des français ça là je préfère
normal que sérieuse bon excuse et de
disco ah ouais
non
je vous demande de vous arrêter pour que
nos amis téléspectateurs puissent se
faire une idée très précise sur le
mental le psychisme des mafieux berne
on va faire une petite interview psy et
on ne vous jugera jingle bouge plus
maintenant je crois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voulez vous relaxer un petit peu avant
de commencer oui
[Applaudissements]
c'est un lien c'est tout vent
riou n'oublie pas c'est un chant
traditionnel tibet j'ai vu gong li la
télévision cette semaine dire que le
tibet était une province de la chine
la tâche durant les jo league anglais
alors est-ce que vous n'êtes pas un an
non pas vraiment est ce que vous êtes
schizo temps son temps avec mon travail
avec votre travail vous êtes maso tant
de temps à qui est ce que vous êtes
sadou est patron non non je vous êtes
sado-maso bon patron géronto géronto
c'est quand on aime les personnes plus
âgées
le personnage moment mais c'est pas
vraiment ça c'est pas votre truc non est
ce que vous êtes porno ça veut dire
qu'on regarde et que cette temps ce
temps je crois le porno
je devine dans le fond là bas qui se dit
mais qu'est ce que je fous là camarades
bien est-ce que vous êtes fétiche au nom
exhibo oui à davos non mais mon travail
c'est vraiment sexy
est ce que vous êtes pitot non bien sûr
non on est une fille de 2 ans et plus
jeune maman c'est un peu ce que vous
êtes zoo ah non pas du tout non je pense
pas exactement j'ai bien non merci
beaucoup et mara
bien on baisse la lumière ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle bells amis
[Musique]
alors je vous faire virginie et corps
allez une petite interview psy c'est
tombé sur vous voulez pas répondre
coralie on va voir ça sur virginie peu
sinon comme avec edouard baer c'est vrai
il y avait pour moi non abbassi si si
est-ce qu est ce que vous êtes parano
les filles
enfin moi un peu ouais enfin bon il faut
qu'il faut c'est que vous êtes schizo
ouais bon totalement non bah non
apparemment non puisque il n'y a pas de
différence entre votre vie
professionnelle et votre vie privée vous
dites que ça fait partie de moi j'ai
beaucoup de facettes différentes mais sa
passe est sans aucun problème très bien
qu elle est ce que vous êtes sado
vaguement quand même vous aimez bien
faire mal ouais j'aime bien des mazots
sont pas trop mais par contre ça dauger
pratiqué pendant que je vais beaucoup
plus jeune vous avez fait la dominatrice
oui et alors alors c'était rigolo mais
on s'en lasse ah oui on s'en lasse aussi
alors vous êtes exhibo oui vous coralie
on le sait vous l'avez dit relais votre
époque gothique en vous éléments sur la
scène de la loco
virginie est ce que vous êtes exhibo non
non pas de géronto pourquoi pas j'ai
honte quand on aime les vieux que le
noir est gérante au sk le noir et
géronto voilà est-ce que vous êtes pédo
plus j'aime plus les garçons que les
hommes en fait voilà donc c'est un peu
pédo je reconnais 6 13
est ce que cette zone voilà non non
jamais essayé des bois est ce que vous
êtes
ayrault c'est quoi ouais pourquoi pas
ouais je vous ai de coco arrive
moi j'ai tout essayé sauf l'hérault en
fait vous êtes coco vous êtes adamo non
être adamo c'est une aberration c'est la
pire de toutes c'est sabine l'an dernier
vous n'êtes pas d'amour ça c'est le vrai
maître tombe la neige et la glace est ce
que vous êtes disco venir lui pas non
plus spécifiquement si j'ai beaucoup bu
pourquoi pas
[Musique]
12 heures
voilà on va commencer avec vos michel
est ce que vous êtes accro à l'alcool
non non à la cigarette non vous n'êtes
pas accro à la cigarette au cigare aussi
garde alors en parlant de cigarettes je
voudrais répondre à un email d'un garçon
qui s'appelle libéral un mec s'appelle
libéral pas très libéral ils me
reprochent
en dix ans on fume sur votre plateau bah
oui moi les gens font ce qu'ils veulent
c'est vrai puisque quand darmon fume si
je les engueule c'est pas parce qu'il
fume c'est parce qu'il écoute pas guy
forget voilà est ce que vous êtes
mythos comme tous les paranos vous êtes
mytho mythomane peut-être vrai mais
peut-être un peu vous je déteste
vous détestez les mythomanes parano est
parano comme tous les skyzos way est ce
que vous n'êtes pas mourinho
de temps en temps vous avez peur vous
sentez que le monde entier contre vous
ça vous arrive le match gasquet a des
problèmes c'est comme atik sécurité
qu'ils allaient paypal à michael et vous
vous êtes parent enfant mais ça m'est
arrivé mais quelques petites fois ses
films l'étranger pour la ouais c'est pas
autant alors mareva est ce que vous êtes
maso ou est ce que vous aimez quand on
vous fait mal ça dépend où
à sa défense ou dix jours et comment ça
dépend où et comment ne vous êtes pas
contre le principe je les adore cette
mer est ce que vous vous êtes masoe mais
qu'on vous fasse mal un peu on avait
namouh est ce que j'espère vous mort
quand on mord c'est non non non mais
j'aime bien les mauvaises critiques que
j'adore ouais j'ai appris aux hackers
est maso s'adosse à 9h et mazeaud comme
tous les ados alors vous tiens tu
connais l'histoire nom dans l'histoire
du mazeau dédié aux ados fais moi mal au
sein de l'isi nom et l'odieux merci
génial c'est très bonne histoire
qu'est-ce que vous êtes exhibo
c'est-à-dire exhibitionniste escales
miami par exemple chez vous promener à
poil avec juste un t-shirt mêlant ses
voisins regardent ça vous aimez vous
montrer un peu tout nu non non je finis
ma vie c'est que sa série finit là non
mais non non je me permets
l'exhibitionnisme dans la maison oui
dans la maison par maison et le jardin
ouais vous êtes tout nu chez vous moi ça
s'appelle pas de l'exhibitionnisme c'est
que j'ai grandi tout nus et en maillot
de bain non mais parce qu'à tahiti
quand on est enfant ben on est tout le
temps à la plage vous êtes encore une
enfant exactement bon est ce que vous
êtes porno comme tous les barjots comme
tous les barjots très bien vous êtes
porno si vous aimez les cassettes pornos
vous regardez défini oui
[Applaudissements]
b
et vous savez chacun peut dernière
question est ce que vous êtes julio ma
maman est très heureux mais ce sésame à
celle chatel qui valent pas d'hier
j'adore parce que j'étais obligé d'être
avec ma maman donc du coup on devient
remiot effectivement mais maintenant que
tu me connais tu y vas donner de plus en
plus elle est révolue au merci beaucoup
didier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] ma fille tu fais chier pas
bonjour je suis allé deux là impeccable
mais qu'est ce que c'est laurent faisant
la liste ans je suis le chef de file des
gens qui ne comprennent pas cette des
juifs résistants et je suis rentré je
vais suivre avait même prendre le maquis
ce soir et tu verras maffrand secondes
tu ne t'en rends pas compte tirer les un
enfant enchaîne bien aurélie dupont est
ce que vous êtes mito non est ce que
vous êtes schizo c'est bientôt
est ce que vous êtes parano un petit peu
à l'opéra de paris est maso forcément un
peu pour faire ce boulot là il fait la
trentaine mais oui les taux resteraient
toi devant une barre pendant des heures
les chaussures en faire aussi si vous
êtes sado
pas encore pas encore ce qui veut dire
tout peut arriver en même temps techcite
toile infernale
si vous êtes exhibo vous avez bien au
premier tout eu dans la fenêtre je veux
pas forcément ça met un peu exhib oui
forcément de danse et 1,5 me ou d'être
de se dévoiler un peu en scène c'est un
peu exhib est ce que vous êtes gérant
taux par rapport au dollar par rapport à
tout le monde comme moi pour le rapport
à moi aussi c'est quand on aime les gens
plus âgés visage et comment le visage ça
dépend entre 50 ans de plus et des ans
de plus ce qu'ils ont de plus pourquoi
pas vrai dix ans de plus pourquoi pas
vous avez quel âge j'ai bientôt 28 ans a
fait 38 dans le baba parce que vous êtes
quand je dis porno c'est pas est ce que
vous regardez cassettes pornos de cette
borne vous regarder je peux pas de
cassettes ça m'arrivait de zapper et de
regarder ça me fait ça m'amuse beaucoup
ça fait beaucoup rire ça fait peur c'est
du travail
j'ai regardé comme tout le monde quoi
qui n'a rien d'un film parmi les tenants
d'un film porno ici vraiment être ta
femme c'est à dire que
il ya le scénario est toujours le même
alors ouais pas tellement mais quand on
l'a vu on l'a tous vu ce ne sont pas
toujours le même nombre
c'est pas sa condition
l'élection est ce que vous êtes disco
oh
[Musique]
plus
la tuer bush non là je suis d'accord
c'est google c'est ça qui m'énerve je
suis en train de chercher un nom pour
l'association bazas état c'est un trek
on les balance c'est à dire que il ya un
moment donné mais balance hésite
beaucoup et un moment donné elles ont
décidé
et alors là c'est plus ça c'est très
très bas aussi vous il là je vous dis
c'est tellement changeant j'en sais rien
peut-être à mon avis j'essaye tous les
signes et deux en fonction de ce qui
vient jérôme hiver donc interview psy
est ce que vous êtes mito ses nerfs
mythomane oui on gère la plupart me
dites pas que c'est pas de la bonne vous
êtes mis torse au sens courant de
l'acceptation du terme
non mais pas mythomane est ce que vous
êtes schizo toujours au sens courant du
terme
bah oui non je ne vais pas me dire non à
chaque fois non plus non mais je vous
répond sincèrement mes excuses au nom ya
pas deux gérard miller n'ont pas eu
cette parano pas du tout je vais te maso
non non ne veux pas qu'on fasse un peu
mal non
d'abord essayé à non mais moi je fais
pas l'amour avec un homme assez
seulement dans l'amour qu'ont fait mal à
brac antoine emaz aussi dans l'amour que
ça non seulement n'ont pas seulement un
pas seulement donc est ce que vous êtes
en genre et pas voter aussi massivement
jacques chirac
on veut être dans 15 personnes qu'est-ce
que vous êtes sado pas du tout non plus
c'est raisonner sado-maso pas du tout
exhibo alors vraiment pour vous donner
un oui ah non mais attendez je fais de
la télévision non vous promener à poil
devant votre fenêtre on se change votre
voisine beauregard a donc là c'est un
sens plus exacte du terme
d'exhibitionnisme n'ont alors pas du
tout pas du tout non vous balader jamais
par exemple sur la plage avec un slip
boulboul non non
est ce que vous êtes cassettes pornos
cassettes pornos non il y avait un des
deux termes où j'aurais pu répondre oui
mais par celle est fourni
est ce que vous êtes gérant taux pas du
tout non vous n'avez pas les vieilles
pas au sens au sens de l'amour au sens
où son physique
oui j'aime bien les vieux oui plutôt et
pas au sérieux non non non je vous êtes
plus d'offrir un peu de ton sur ton
quand on vieillit ça devient mais c'est
vrai vous voyez vue plutôt pédo alors
non plus parce que feydeau c'est en
dessous de la loi et de la tolérance
humaine
non non pas du tout mais je n'avais le
droit j'ai rajouté de la loi et de la
tolérance humaine si marion noire n'ont
cessé de la tolérance humaine c'est à
dire je suis pour qu'à certains moments
la loi coïncide avec cette idée
construit de l'humanité est ce que vous
êtes jo je vous auront moi c'est l'eau
c'est un plus trop tard vous n'êtes pas
doué pour que les gens répondent oui
pourquoi pas moi parce que je réponds
non
il y en a qui m'ont jamais personne n'a
dit oui là je vais vous dire franchement
êtes fétiche au nom fétiche au nom
travelo bruche non mais c'est amusant
c'est que finalement votre idée de
l'interview psy c'est un and1 interview
qui se situe entièrement du côté de la
perversion fleury sub arabe
oui non c'est pas mal non
avec un point comme son corps dans ce
qu'il faut que vous sachiez c'est que de
tous les patientes les psychanalystes
voit ce qu'on ne voit quasiment jamais
c'est lé pervers
jamais un masochiste jamais un
exhibitionniste quasiment jamais devient
voir un psychanalyste pourquoi parce
qu'il sait parfaitement quel est son
objet de jouissance il n'a pas besoin de
s'allonger sur un divan pour savoir ce
qu'il a besoin ce dont il a besoin
je faisais de disques au disco
là j'aurai vous dire
en fait ce qu'il veut faire
on va vous faire une petite interview
très sérieuse mais la route est longue
attention on ne bouge pas pendant le
dîner rouge
mon cher bouche merde la révolution
personne bouge par le single se voulant
gérer c'est fou les ips vicieux de la
même couleur berling et dave oui c'est
vrai que c'est beau ouais ça change tout
cela non sans fin
y aller marche mieux qu'à limoux au
blaireau godet est ce que vous n'êtes
pas non beaucoup disent ah vous êtes
exhibo oui djibo oui alors vous alors
j'ai quelqu'un qui est exceptionnel
c'est un staff un oui oui comme tous les
acteurs le sens et on serait pas peur
oui mais moi je les enfants peuvent
l'être aussi des fois oui oui vous
marcher nu devant les fenêtres et cette
dernière se serait offert plus de 300 kg
je marche nu devant ma fenêtre il ya une
espèce de rideau rouge fermé tous les
jours tous les jours à longueur de
journée et que de temps en temps un
quart d'heure par jour le rideau s'ouvre
j'aimerais c'est quoi je parle pas des
chaînes lg moi habitent en face de chez
vous nous sortez de joe dante et parle
un belge des agents taux de gayssot
corton plus que jamais bon rassurez-vous
jean-claude monsieur le ministre vous
posez des questions bien alors on
continue parce que vous êtes moins faux
nom
maso sauf quand je te dise de l'été
renom mais aussi un peu maso ah ouais
c'est bien savoir faire à tous les deux
la plus réputée passadou un peu sado
vous aussi vous aimez bien faire mal
cette borne où l'on regarde les
cassettes pornos à d'abord christian n'a
pas mais ça existe pas beaucoup les
femmes je crois je crois que les hommes
regardent la brunante saisir au max
ouais ça je crois que les hommes on aura
une relation à l'acte sexuel du film est
comme ça cru qui les excite et les
femmes ça n'existe pas
ben c'est à dire le la tristesse qui a
trouvé plus que le plaisir station enfin
bon tournoi
toi mais c'est risque en laissant finit
mal sans jouer les prudes et tout ça il
m'est arrivé d'être excités mais à
regret ah bon oh oui ça medic va vous a
excité quand même oui mais vraiment un
regret quoi est-ce que vous êtes
toujours non je suis pas gay sous
géronto c'est pareil gérant toffin
sûrement pas sûrement pas sûrement pas
il ya d'ailleurs que j'ai lâché mes deux
bras n'ont pas non plus mais non je ne
l'étais pas oui mais qui dit oui les
sentais pas dole et santos in memoriam
et on peut le dire je sais mais chassez
à des lacets et adolescentes au fil wi
fétiche au j'aime bien les chaussures
les gants à l'élégance ya en fait c'est
pas du tout tromper la main dans l'huile
bouillante
si les zones on joue non aux mondiaux
n'ont pas non oui
[Musique]
bien est-ce que vous êtes lesbo vous est
hétéro finalement je crois finalement
vous avez découvert qu'après tout c'est
tjrs hétéro mais j'étais à la base j'ai
fait un petit détour par ren détour de
10 ans mais cher et ça c'est devenu une
parenthèse voilà mais vous revenez
maintenant à l'hétérosexualité
ouais ça vous plaît vous avez un mec là
sérieusement non ben alors lancé un
appel c'est que ça marche c'est que
larusso prenons larusso par exemple la
reçoit lancé un appel dans cette
émission la trouvais injuste s'appelle
fabrice il très bien grâce à l'émission
grâce avait mis tu veux lancer un appel
plus cher qui veut de moi voilà sa
promenade jeannot c'est qu'ils les
agoras est ce que vous êtes tous trop
c'est vrai ça va peut être être un peu
stressée annonce on sortait de chez vous
agoraphobe et qui vous faisait des
courses et bunge élèves sur trottoir
d'en face il voir une épicerie donc je
me suis ruiné pendant un an et je t'ai
truc super cher je peux pas sortir
jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise que que si ça
continue elle allait falloir materner
parce que je peux pas aller chercher mes
cigarettes et j'ai eu peur est là
je me suis soigné tout seul tu finis
mais c'est gérable mais là ça va
comment est ce que vous êtes nympho je
crois pas je sais ça veut dire quoi
une info man c'est une fille qui a
besoin de beaucoup d'hommes beaucoup de
rapports sexuels journée pour le rapport
lui même juste pour l'acte non non vous
êtes mito non plus les skyzos
concrètement qu'est-ce qui a touché la
queue devant dinosaures et de jeu à
trois barques sent le mec qui vient
nettoyer mon fils et dinosaures de
gaston cela quand même
ils viennent pour l'accueil de monde il
est enfin sexy de tous et allez zou
n'êtes pas un homme
ouais maso certainement quand je mets
bien qu'on me fasse mal oui en fait
l'amour de dire qu'on vous parle nous
avons non ça dépend de la personne ne
sait rien si entre qu'il monte ça fait
pas de mal mais je sais pas besoin de ça
vous êtes gérant taux pendant géronto
quand on aime les yeux pas jusqu'à
maintenant vous êtes zone cocody
toto
est-ce que d'amour est ce que vous êtes
à damour sous-estiment vachement un
amour donc vous êtes quand même je vous
êtes métro boulot dodo
non vous êtes disco voit la super star
ami scott c'est flammarion pour savoir
vraiment qui vous êtes on va faire une
interview ci met en bouche par un jingle
bien alors est ce que vous êtes mytho
oui skeezo oui parano oui un peu moins
mais oui bazot
non pas trop ce dos oui ça d'eau non
plus exhibo un peu oui
gérante au pas du tout pédo non on sent
quand même que
il apparaît non parce que c'est pas
légal et berner par les deux mains se
lèvent tout à leur fétiche oh non ça va
adamo non gayssot oui oui vous êtes tous
finalement non mais sérieusement non
mais tous les virus en fait
gérante au sol gérant tôt il aime pas
les vieilles ouais non mais lévis où la
cité d'ailleurs dans le bouquin que vous
avez sorti sur wild lévis où la
perversité c'est en fait où elle
décrivait que la perversité c'était un
mythe inventé par les bonnes gens pour
expliquer l'étrange attraits de certains
autres la perversité lévis je pense que
c'est une façon de deux places et deux
belles journées quoi c'est pas forcément
désagréable
je suis sûr que si on répondait tous à
ce questionnaire ils y auraient chacun
de nous ré davis comme ça je sais pas je
voulais pas chez les gens
julia qui peut dire qu'il n'y a aucun
vice évidemment way et qui peut dire que
c'est un vice oui
on ne bouge pas par le single
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette masure assez parlé vous dites bien
quand même un certain plaisir à un
moment imaginé que je pourrais l'être en
gros wen en tiff
oui non il ya des situations de quelques
fois je me demande si je ne suis pas un
petit peu bien vous jouez vous répondre
franchement c'est bien parce que vous
êtes sado vous et quand vraiment on
m'embête j'imagine oui c'est ça mais
vous faites pas mal à votre fiancée
comme ça pour lui faire du bien j'ai pas
manqué de chance je suis à un moment
tout le monde a cru que j'étais avec
alexandre jardin
mais j'essaie remet à coupon rigueur
n'était on était effondré
nicolas ghetti avec des makes rivette
personne m'emmerde il n'y a pas de
problèmes qui n'ont plus bas qu'ils
n'ont plus mythos oui un peu mytho ouais
bah oui ça fait du bien c'est pas il
faut un peu dans les métiers qu'on fait
oui parano par nourrit beaucoup et je
retiens tout les bains comme tout le
monde je crois
tous les trucs mauvais en retient puis
tous les compliments risque était que
tout ouïe où tout d'un coup on va me
dire un truc à la cour n'avait pas donné
de faire comme il est sage ce soir je
trouve est ce que vous êtes exhibo pas
pas trop là au cap d'agde se dit la
serviette et vous n'aviez bon c'est pas
trop mon truc géronto les vieux des
vieux de 51 ans est ce que je serais
qu'un mec comme vous nous un peu trop
vieux non
c'est bien
en même temps et michèle rey l'année
soit je suis quarante neuf mois loin
quand on cherche on trouve non pas
franchement bien est-ce que vous êtes
porno vous regardez des cassettes pornos
j'ai fait un truc mieux que ça ouais
c'est un scoop
j'ai doublé un film porno orlov
abonderait c'est pas parce que j'avais
besoin d'argent c'est klapisch qui a
réalisé un court métrage porno et j'ai
fait une des actrices de sa gauche
je me souviens plus du tennis attend pas
le texan je passe je peux dire tout ce
que vous voulez je vous ai dans
l'oralité sur le ce pour vous le la
perversion passe par l'oralité vous avez
vous aimé dire des mots un peu soulagé
ça me dérange pas du tout j'ai pas de
problème avec ça ouais c'est dommage que
je sois trop vieux pauvres yapi bon ben
il faut qu'on inverse les rôles c'est le
gage que j'avais accepté
allez viens ici
[Applaudissements]
marrant je me sens mieux payé là alors
qu'ils regardaient ce rebond soir soit
reconnaissait le principe on va faire
l'interview psy ah ouais c'est
l'interruption
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle on ne
bouge pas pendant le jean galle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu connais des questions alors su quand
on refile jean galant rallume maintenant
alors je vais bouger sur ma fille moi on
leur faire en bouche pendant le jingan
[Applaudissements]
oui
ça représente vous faire belle maison
mais là où tu es très con c'est que je
dirais pour la prochaine les chapitres
j'ai pas pensé oui tu prendras kad et
olivier
c'est con comme un comique à faire alors
est ce que tu es sado ouais j'aime bien
faire mal j'aime bien le pain c'est le
bout des seins maso ouais temps en temps
j'aime bien me faire passer le bout des
seins claustro claustro non pas du tout
au contraire j'adore être pas de chaleur
enfermé que la jazz heures être enfermé
tous à jouer
mythos nitoo bah oui je me prends pour
thierry ardisson donc sunnito schizo
schizo bah oui je suis quatre
personnages à la fois je suis un ami
avait écrit que j'étais à la fois que je
voulais être daniel filipacchi patrick
sabatier et paul morand et finalement
j'étais un peu des trois aujourd'hui
chez un peu plus thierry ardisson parano
de moins en moins de parano mais c'est
vrai que pendant des années je pensais
que tout le monde disait du mal de moi
puis un jour la profession peut décerner
un 7 d'or est donc depuis je sais que
tout le monde madore l'espace jean luc
et xivo part dans aig dont j'aime bien
balader à poil et mes enfants me le
reproche déjà dispo toi aura un temps
tué mes enfants me raccroche à blanc
[ __ ] le mans je me suis habillé une fois
en fille dans bad minuit aux bains
douches et ça m'allait pas le nom
fétiche aux as
j'aime bien oui j'aime bien des petits
objets des petits souvenirs les pieds
géronto gérant tour pas du tout alors
c'est marrant je suis au plus tôt l'
inverse la pédo zone non non non je
pourrais pas faire l'amour avec mon
cheval parce qu'il ya une trop grosse
[ __ ]
ragot pardon ragot est ce que je suis
rien aux achats d'or les ragots et ça te
les ragots sur la profession safem le
dernier à qui marche le mieux en ce
moment c'est le restaurant de jean luc
delarue qui s'appelle la redevance parce
que c'est vous qui l'avez payé
est ce que tu es sanglots sanglots ouais
je suis sanglots quand je vais voir le
film de joe louis et bacri le goût des
autres ou qu'on tombe de nos sept d'or
chasser sanglots obispo
non non honnêtement je suis pas obispo
n'en sage et plus en plus même si je
devenais obispo je me fais attention
comme mass turbo de moins en moins mais
floire bas parce que plus tu es célèbre
what they must urbain
est ce que tu es populo je suis populo
moi je viens du peuple donc évidemment
j'ai aucun mépris pour le tabac puisque
j'en viens on va laisser un peu à tous
de reprendre sa place
non
mais si on se fait trop
on ne couche pas le king
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vient alors si vous êtes schizo je ne
pourrais pas rester dans un film c'est à
dire porter sur mes épaules un film en
tant que metteur en scène
est ce que vous êtes parano oui oui oui
en fait je crois que je souffre de
toutes les pathologies
bon d'accord base vous lui dites
seulement oui alors est ce que vous êtes
maso non j'aime pas vous pourrez est ce
que vous êtes sado non est ce que vous
êtes seau d'eau ça dort à est ce que
vous êtes exhibo est ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes nympho non géronto
ça dépend de l'âge cinquante deux ans
ces vieux 52 ans alors oui voilà eh ben
voilà
hélène de fougerolles voilà et 54 c'est
pour la vie viennent savourer dimanche
soir un cadre non ça va hein pourquoi
pas bon c'est bien tant tout de même six
ans ahmed qui attend là bas qui se dit
[ __ ] c'est pas mal quand même 52 54 à
toutes tes chances quand même mais les
geeks sont fiancés en a vingt-six aulas
maintenant je le déteste ce type déjà je
suis déjà j'aime pas ce truc là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous avez bougé oui je vous dit tout sur
cette émission a maintenant je la suis
un bon rallume dans sa laurent vous avez
été exemple tu toi au moins tu as été
exemplaire vous citiez attention
interview psy il bouge pendant le jingle
bonnes réponses
thierry en dessous je réponds à caroline
qui n'ont rien email en dix ans fait
toujours l'interview au psi à des filles
banon je la fais un garçon et c'est
beaucoup plus excitant
si vous êtes parano par exemple je vais
abénex quand il a lancé son fils me l'a
dit la chasse au bénin que s'est ouverte
alors tout le monde à les mélanger pas
de chasse au bénin ex personne ne l'a vu
encore donc c'est un peu de la parano
est ce que vous vous êtes un peu comme
ça à croire que tout le monde vous
déteste c'est tout non non non non je
pense pas non non non mais par rapport à
jean jacques je pense que il ya des gens
qui l'attendait au cou avec un couteau
quand même avec quand même c'est que
c'est vrai ces raisons là je pense au
contraire même qu'il a été très sucré
très spirituel paramore d'accord à cette
phrase est ce que c'est ce qu'ils au nom
claustro oui c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je ne fais pas de théâtre
ouais et
même en gymnase même ses prix le gymnase
s'est pris pour trois ans je vous êtes
exhibo oui non pas trop
vous n'êtes pas exhibo non pas tant que
ça magnéto serge vous êtes l'info oui
pas forcément que jamais jamais me
tapait beaucoup de femmes mais j'aime
bien refaire plusieurs fois c'est
duracell fétiche au bois panaro à chaque
fois ça y est sadow non pas bon non vous
aimez pas d'enseignement au mot vais-je
été violée à l'âge de 13 ans par un
pédophile donc avant c'est vrai j'ai du
mal dans ce cas là je savais pas ça
maintenant personne ne le savait à
setefi la bravade je le dis je suis sur
le cul
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai c'est bien
c'est courageux de dire ça
parce que si vous applaudissez trop ça
va encourager les pédophiles en même
temps ces courageuses qui fait et il ne
sera d'oser quoi vous et qu'on arrête là
parce que non pourquoi non têtards d'eau
oui ça m'arrive
ouais c'est honteux comment peux tu mon
coco non ayrault non adamo oui mais
enfin il ya bien longtemps
bernardo 2.0 sur mu et de nador bien
est-ce que vous êtes disco non voilà
jean hugues anglade
jacques beineix
avec une boule rose rouge pound single
[Musique]
bien j'ai bougé il a bougé
charlotte je bougeais obliger leurs
enfants à l'école est ce que vous êtes
charlotte rampling est ce que vous êtes
mythos je dois pas être parce que je
connais pas le mot est ce que vous êtes
schizo un petit peu mais c'est no parano
non claustro légèrement sado non pas aux
miens exhibo a way home au nom adamo si
le tas d'amour ici nous sommes rassurés
parce que vous êtes disco oui
[Musique]
dans l'air
il
m
[Musique]
voilà merci beaucoup merci sur l'ogre au
[Applaudissements]
mont nebo cheval pendant le single on ne
bouge pas pendant le single
[Musique]
c'est l'interview psy si hockey est ce
que vous êtes mytho non non mythomane
non j'aime bien dans le spectacle il ya
beaucoup de personnages qui sont
complètement mytho mais moi dans la vie
je suis pas je suis pas spécialement me
thonon non et je détecte souvent les
mythomanes parole j'adore ça quand il ya
quelqu'un qui a ri commence à parler que
sa part il commence à raconter n'importe
quoi ça c'est fabuleux 1
c'est une détecte là où d'ailleurs tard
je vous écoute et il croit elle lui
raconte qu'il était à l'elysée
pourquoi est ce que vous êtes skeezo
tison je suis skizomeuh ouais ouais
ouais ben obligatoirement quand
don en masse sur ce canton a sur scène
mais c'est pas non plus très très loin
de ce que je suis dans la vie parano
parano complètement complètement croyais
tout le monde vous déteste du match de
vous non non mais je suis parano ou quoi
c'est ça non mais pas non non c'est pas
ça
non c'est pas ça la parade
non parce que par aveu c'est avec son
frère avec son frère et son copain
hôpitaux est un peu parano c'est ça
donne un exemple si tout le monde de
vitesse
je ne fais pas la paranoïa par rapport à
par rapport à ça par exemple mais par
pour plein de trucs je fais s'il ya un
bruit ou je fais je bloque vite sur la
réserve en cfa parano voilà je viens je
suis pas parano je fais d'accord c'est
pas parano c'est trop de choses qui
arrivent
j'aime pas comment vous émission vous
posez la question sourire quelques
années bien maso non vous n'aimez pas
les saintes
ça c'est bon c'est pas pareil c'est pas
j'aime bien les ça j'aime bien timé papa
jusqu'à la douleur a d'abord justin cinq
ans ça donne des petits frissons
il est sympa c'est dommage mais je me
régale
battus à celle fille
bien est-ce que vous êtes ado ça d'orane
on ne va pas faire mal
non une petite fessée de temps en temps
je dis bah j'aime bien la petite fessée
cantal ont bien mérité le titre et c'est
là je te regarde encore une fois mais
oui oui bah t'es pas obligé de la
prochaine question c'est pas obligé de
regarder mais est-ce que vous êtes
saudeau petit enfin franchement oui
bailly si on répond franchement bien
tout le temps mais moi je réponds tout
temps franchement de la vie je suis pas
un passionné avant jeu n'ont cependant
annoncé wayne dans un des fois quand
pour donner un petit peu de piquant
c'est à dire c'est un peu comme les
aventuriers par l'ancien je suis pas
allé dans ce pays
et oui vous êtes sur france 2 chef du
service québec madame monsieur gillett
exhibo bizarrement je suis assez chasse
est réservé et c'est par exemple j'aime
pas téléphoner devant des gens certains
trucs mais par contre c'est vrai que
faire faire l'amour dans d'autres
personnes
ouais ça peut être sympa d'en payer
il ya du bon ben là il ya 2 3 millions
de gens est-ce que vous êtes homo ah non
je vais être trio oui la première fois
la terreur
voilà mes parents regardent ça bien
jouer et de montrer par me dit l'air
d'aller chercher une bière dans le frigo
ouais ouais est ce que vous êtes fétiche
au nom pas porno vous regardez des
cassettes ça m'a passé ça chauffe ça
ridicule mais c'est vers 12 13 ans vous
avez votre époque
ouais ben c'était les débuts par contrat
est ce que vous êtes géronto gérante on
constate des gens plus vieux à
ah non non une fille de 32 ans mais bon
ouais voilà non jusqu'à 40
richard d'accord parce que jusqu'à 50 60
est ce que vous êtes zoo moi je sais pas
tant des sénateurs groupe six mois oui
oui mais c'est l'interview qu surtout il
ya un mec qui m'a envoyé un email
non mais dis non non il ya mais qui
m'ont envoyé un e-mail pourquoi tu te
demande pas aux invités quand tu fais
une interview psy vous avez de la chance
c'est pas tomber sur vous avez vu et toi
non plus est ce que vous êtes nécro à la
haine et ces noms scato et des fois ça
on n'est pas uniquement maintenant jusqu
à tous par exemple la toile aussi n'ont
pas dit que tu es est ce que vous êtes
adamo non adamo qu'est ce que tu attends
parade amoureuse qu'on est madame
okayama d'amour oui alors je refuse dire
que de mettre à de la nabo voilà donc
c'était que sur le m
ça met en cause la question est ce que
vous êtes adamo pendant l'acte sexuel
c'est obligatoire une fois d'amour
si l'eau n'arrive pas tickle
voir l'interview ci n'est pas seulement
réservé aux filles puisque vous donner à
la caisse que vous allez en être la
victime
je suis jamais montré que seigneur
[Musique]
une
il a bougé mais je suis assez grand
allume ses casses couilles on n'est pas
couché je regarde pas l'émission
pourquoi sa venue de fait du cheval ou
quoi
les délateurs faut faire rigueur alors
que guillaume canet on va voir
maintenant que l'interview psy n'est pas
seulement réservé aux filles puisque
vous en être la victime
[Musique]
du
j'ai mal chauffés elle regarde regarde
bien
alors vous connaissez le principe est ce
que vous êtes mito quand ça m'arrange
enfin parano ouais ouais terrible schizo
eux n'ont pas grave ça schizo ouais non
non non non mais elle me l'a fait avant
l'art gars incroyable ne me regardez pas
voilà je vous demande un truc
faites-le pour ma femme mes enfants j'ai
de la famille c'est gentil arrêté de me
regarder voilà bien si si regardez moi
ma jo maso non pas du tout ma zone non
peut-être vous avez peut-être des fois
j'aime bien me faire du mal mais
psychologiquement physiquement non
juridiquement non non les bougies tout
cela non non c'est ado non non plus loin
sous dos non non plus exhibo ouais non
non c'est vrai mais mais en privé ouais
mais c'est quand vous êtes tout seul
segment pas tous ces exemples notamment
ma télé géants éloignés
non mais avec des proches en fait je
m'en rends compte que j'aime bien et
montrer mon cul tout ça ouais fétiche oz
fétiche au nom sait pas très bien si ça
j'aime c'est vrai le harass l'adresse et
le porno
vous l'aurez cassettes pornos vrai bah
ouais bon comme tout le monde j'aime
bien écouter que l'as laisse que vous
êtes vibro non non on va quoi biberon
c'est quoi les brosser le space mountain
gens qui aiment les films utiliser des
biberons
est ce que vous êtes trio non non non je
vais essayer si bon si vous appelez
tissu mais les jeunes filles et un
garçon aux deux garçons une fille non de
finir son nom mais c'était très
longtemps mais voilà mais est ce fini
tout ça alcoolo
non non j'aime bien boire un coup comme
monde quoi non je me lève pas avec le
102 matin pétards d'eau oui est ce que
vous êtes kadéos oui mais non non non
c'est sincèrement ils savent que je les
aime beaucoup un bon maintenant c'est
jacques martin c'est gentil fils de
taloches pas facile
fadiga
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien facile à l'interview que vous êtes
mito pas du tout mythe au jeu vous êtes
parano totalement ah oui je prends tout
pour moi noté chez vous vous faites de
petites croix en face est ce que vous
êtes schizo non peu le tout mazeau
oiseaux wade et petites brûlures aux
cigarettes temps en temps j'aime bien
défini
est-ce que vous êtes san ou pas du tout
vous savez pas faire mal gérante au
premier
j'aurais pu montrer moi je suis pas trop
attiré sexuellement par le vie en
général non non je riais pedro non non
plus on paie l'eau exhibo pas du tout
vous avez pas vous avez échappé car
j'apprends encore soit être terrible
pour le fétiche qu'elle non un féticheur
non plus aux mots du coup pourquoi j'ai
fait du coup je me suis levé à 6
est ce que vous êtes est ce que vous
êtes corps nous tue à vous regarder des
cassettes pornos le soir chez vous non
pas régulièrement ça va arriver ça vous
est arrivé avec david haba en écoutant
sa chanson ding corgan josette vibro
masseur
non pas du tout triaud non je sais que
c'est super à la main on me l'a proposé
plusieurs fois et vous avez refusé
ouais bon la femme ne m'attire pas un
gigolo tu appelles utopie le [ __ ]
n'enlevait clitoris est trop forte
zelko l'eau
non je suis saoul après deux verres donc
ouais donc batardeau anciennement mais
plus anciennement mais plus qu au col
parti ou à la drogue
la drogue ah non pas du tout pas du tout
ça va être dur à cannes alors on m'avait
prévenue mais je n'ai rien vu bien je
vous êtes héros héros de la drogue au
smic non je suis pas drôle du tout
vous êtes disco avant
cependant le génial
[Musique]
bien plus cette interview psy vous
connaissez non en face si la secousse
est mythomane mito impôt un peu parano
beaucoup schizo non maso un peu voilà
vous aimez bien souffrir un peu
psychologiquement ou physiquement
j'ai moins doux mélange des deux mais
quand même bien de passer ou mordus ça
peut arriver et ça donc ça va avec un
petit peu aussi un peu sado maso vous
avez une robe en vinyle chez vous vous
êtes homo j'ai essayé vous a pas plu si
c'était très excitant
ouais non vous êtes vibro non je vous
êtes trio non plus vous avez jamais
essayé non non mais non la suite encore
je veux bien le croire la toute petite
la pub à bout 1 ce sont bien ces
tensions non quand elle était petite
n'acceptez pas ce genre de chose quand
elle était petite tout le monde appelait
babouins donc vous n'avez jamais essayé
non plus ce trio non vous avez essayé
franchement non je crois que ça doit
rester un fantasme éthiques
c'est de l'ordre du fondeur vous êtes
géronto c'est à partir de quel âge
non je déconne 50 parce que pas du tout
géronto présente notre ami avait assez
des mises a dit terry lhermitte à côté
de vous pas du tout un pays magique
chéri le vrai thierry lhermitte et ça
vous dit non et vous les vieux n'ont pas
forcément vieux mai
une plume airways pédo non à dos même
pas les ados ou exhibo bas 6 1
ouais un peu exhib haut mais chez vous
aussi vous simplement sur la scène
oui chez moi je suis tranquille ouais je
suis seul il ya des gens qui ont des
voisins qui regarde je me pose c'est
bien ce que je dis est ce que vous êtes
fétiche oh non non pas du tout porno
vous regardez des cassettes pornos ça
peux m'amuser mais seul solo peut-être
solo finalement peut-être d'infos non
pas du tout pipeau non non et disco très
[Applaudissements]
vous savez marcel desailly qu'on ne
bouge pas en ordinaire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien jugnot bien interview psy
donc si vous êtes parano un peu oui
du fait de ma profession oui un petit
peu vous avez peur que les gens disent
du mal de vous comme ça par derrière
disons que je prête beaucoup attention à
ce que j'en dise quelquefois trop quoi
en guerre de ma femme est ce que vous
êtes mégalo non mythos peut-être
quelques fois vous êtes schizo maso
peut-être vous aimez bien qu'on vous
fasse mal attention c'est du passé
c'est marrant je mêle du splendid est-ce
que vous êtes sado vous aimez faire mal
non vous aimez faire souffrir non pas de
tacler la cave où il devra du rosaire de
type s vous êtes trop qu il a du talent
mais non en fait je veux dire c est ce
que vous êtes ton monte comme nous jeune
trentenaire
c'est normal plusieurs rosazza place
mais déjà très très contente d'être à
côté de lui chaque chose en son temps
est ce que vous êtes homo non que je
sache
est ce que vous êtes gros lolos oui
enfin changer de place est ce que vous
êtes trio et à et deux et trois zéro
j'aime essayer même nom marcel il faut
il faut tout essayer marcel mais enfin
il a peur d'avoir la barre transversale
est ce que vous êtes exhibo un petit peu
mal à vue à des reportages sous les
douches en 37 ans qui prime avec ça non
c'est parce qu'il est jacques chirac
c'est pour ça je vous êtes porno j'ai dû
avoir ma période comme tout le monde
d'avant guerre
est ce qui vous arrive de chamallows
chamallows jamais très bien la chance
est ce que vous êtes pétards d'eau non
non dans ma profession ses clients dont
l'intro de contrô lé gardien qui est
fait
est ce que vous êtes adamo oui je suis
je trouve bien le voilà
[Musique]